foreign
places last time yeah I'll copy that in
the valley by the abandoned Schoolhouse
thanks Bungie
morning big guy how's your head ah a
little fuzzy yeah mine too everything
all right yeah I'm gonna give you guys
the VIP tour today we'll go through the
private section of the reserve avoidance
just be us and Wildlife
this is so very clearly right here I'm
attached just because you wrote your
name on it how it doesn't mean it's not
true this is my hat hey guys
[Music]
settles the Hat issues
anyway now you're ready for Safari yes
where are we heading uh
some of the most incredible creatures on
the planet hopefully
[Music]
look at that just whatever
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
there's an old school house so Bungie
will be just around the corner here
they put a school in the middle of rocks
yeah it used to be used by the
families that worked in the mine over
the hill there but in the copper mine
ran dry
so they shut down the school
ah there's our man
stay close to the vehicle please okay
no
this is amazing it's perfect thank you
yeah Nate this is Bungie
and his daughters good this is my
daughter this is Nora and Matt hello oh
my God that's beautiful yeah
Bungie tracks the movement of the pride
through the reserve yeah that's a great
job hey man thank you and that up there
is the nandy pride yep it's named after
that magnificent matriarch in the middle
there wow yeah I've been the males uhuda
and his brother
and then we uh are we safe right here oh
you're safe you're safe they just
finished off last night's kill okay good
yeah that is insane
okay he's just letting you know see the
way it works with lions is the females
do the hunting the males protect the
pride we'll protect them from work
usually from other Lions any lion from
outside the family comes into their
territory Kuda and clawei will leap onto
it start ripping it apart limb from limo
Die Trying it's the law of the Jungle
guys
it's only law that mattered that yeah
and a rifle is that
book rifle
don't need it
should we do this yep so you just like
put it there okay so the dog so I
usually go off to the smallest one so
you might want to hang on to that okay
you can't have this you definitely can't
you're not going out there right
what is he doing he's good he's gonna go
just showing them he's not afraid
you raised them from Cubs actually set
them all to the wild when they were
still young hey boys great I see you
boys
I love my boys
[Music]
ah
who's a big boy
Jesus
what's happened to your girl
what's wrong with nundy
Andy
you okay my girl
okay okay
just coming a little closer what's wrong
with your poor girl
please listen let me look at you just
want to have a look let me see okay all
right okay I'm going I'm going
YG yeah
she's got a wound on her paw I think
it's a bullet but I can't be sure I've
got to get any closer but that's not
gonna happen now so see if you can find
the vet okay this is too many bajimi now
no problem what is
poachers illegal Hunters
that was really nice you always got to
make a show of yourself huh
you wanna have a guy me yeah come on dad
I'll just hug a line and take a picture
with me oh my dad's not much of a hugger
no no more of a Fizz bumper I am a
hugger well I'm gonna try to get some
help
it's very nice to meet you very nice to
meet you all right Bungie all right Nate
talk to me brother
what happened out there she wasn't too
happy uh
female she's got wounded her poachers
this is a stronger Village just up the
road guys do you mind if we stop by
there
I just want to ask people if they saw
anything
so you think uh maybe someone at the
Village might have seen what happened
yeah since I think heard something
anything unusual you know
so you sure you don't want to line up
last chance
I'm good all right good
it's getting worse and worse poachers
used to just be off to the elephants and
the rhinos now they're actively going
after the Lions why they sell the teeth
the claws even the bones on the black
market that's horrible yeah there's a
market for them now as well the walls
well I don't know man I mean I've read
about the antipolders online and they
said
what she read about the antibodies
online yes and what did it say Nora
what did it say okay well they said that
people have actually hunted down and
killed the poachers
I mean you've heard of stories like that
right Uncle Mario
right
um yeah so are you some kind of an
anti-portrait I mean you just you're
just trying to protect the animals in
every sense
[Music]
foreign
okay so guys listen this is not a
tourist Village
okay it's a
it's an actual real place where people
live
please just be as polite as possible
maybe we get a little drink at the bar
here at the dogs oh no
you can take pictures but just ask them
first okay okay let's all goes some of
the most polite and kind people you'll
ever meet
they speak of type of vendor well mom
was actually teaching Noah and I before
she died
wow you sound good I like that thanks
Dad
where's everybody
hello hello hello
that doesn't look like a Dalmatian dogs
stop taking pictures
do you think Uncle Martin kills poachers
what do you think that's what the
article said Auntie poachers do
Laura you can't just wander off
does that frighten you no I have a
rainbow of emotions at my disposal mayor
well you look scared to me I'm not
scared man uh-huh
hey guys don't walk off just stay close
all right